Luke here with the outo boys YouTube
channel and it is a beautiful cold fall
day here in Alaska I'm building
Bushcraft shelters watching the Northern
Lights cooking amazing food and having a
great
[Music]
[Applause]
time
[Music]
that's a big old moose print right
there the whole place stinks of rotten
salmon it's a smell I associate with the
fall wherever there's salmon there's
usually
Bears there's lots of salmon on the
Beach well I didn't bring a tent with me
so I'm looking for places to build a
shelter
tonight look at that it's a small black
bear print that's his front pad right
there there's his toes and his
claws see this that's a bald eagle print
right there you can see his talons you
see he walked all over
here it's a wolf print he went down here
and came
back the print of a little fox right
there a couple coyote
prints
there that right there and there all the
animals are walking the beach looking
for salmon nothing but stinking fish now
though
I see a few spots that could work as
shelters in a pinch but I'm going to
keep
looking yeah that wouldn't be a bad spot
to get out of the rain I'm kind of
liking this spot there's lots of wood
around for Fire and Building
Materials
man I've been using this saw for 3 years
now two years now thing's done
good tell you what this is a beautiful
spot on a beautiful day and it's
tempting to try to just sleep out under
the the stars but it's going to get cold
bitterly cold tonight the low is
supposed to be around 20° F but there's
a stiff cold wind coming off that Lake
luckily that Hill shelters us a little
bit if you go just 100 ft that way the
wind is just in your teeth so the most
important thing my shelter can do is
block that
wind
all right I got a nice little shelter
here got this natural awning that'll
keep the frost and Rain off me got this
wind break up I think it's time to build
a fire and make some
lunch bought this on our last trip to
Japan it's my first time trying it
out that works pretty good for taking
limbs off
trees
we're going to make fire with a piece of
flint rock and steel going to catch a
spark with the charred linen
cloth got a piece of shredded up jute
here there we go
it's getting really toasty in here with
that fire this enclosed space captures
the heat really
well
we got some boiling bag rice we're going
to put in
there while my lunch is cooking I'm
going to go ahead and set up some
fishing
gear we're going to try to catch some
lake
trout got GL of salmon
eggs
we'll see what
happens got a nice chunk of pork side
right
[Music]
here well I just saw some bites on my
fishing
rod my bait got stolen so there's
something out
there it's all only 2:30 and the sun's
already gone behind the mountain and it
gets so cold once that sun goes away I
can see I'm getting hit little tiny hits
there's definitely some fish out there
messing with my bait question is whether
they're big enough to swallow the
hook ooh there might be something on
there oh most my bait's
gone got a bag of EMP pinatas
here I got a little jar of cholula's
green pepper hot sauce
here there we go pretty simple meal
fried pork side hot tortillas salted
rice and a little a bit of green pepper
hot
sauce oh I love these little EMP pinatas
it's a Savory South American pastry it's
like if a burrito in a Hot Pocket had a
baby a little midday dessert
here
there must be a whole school of little
tiny fish out there cuz I keep getting
bit up and all my bait stolen but
nothing's hooking
up got some black beans
here
we're going to make some good beans
all right the beans are cooked now I'm
adding some pork onions and jalapenos
and yellow lentils and rice cook so
fre a oh man I just dumped about half my
beans in the fire my little pot hanger
broke and dumped half my food in the
fire well I guess that's why you bring
extra
right
look at
that got my tortillas warming up in the
gravel got crispy pork side beans and
rice M batas and tortillas that is a
meal fit for a king right
there that is so so
delicious oh that was good I am so
full
all right there we
go well it's late and it's getting
really really cold I think it's time to
hop in my bag and I'll see you guys in
the
[Music]
morning oh my goodness it is cold I
think I need to get some water boiling
and make something warm to
drink the fire went out around 2:00 a.m.
so I woke up and put some wood on it and
when I looked up there was the best
northern lights display I have seen in a
long time they stretched from Horizon to
Horizon I got out of my bag and set up
my GoPro and I tried to record it but it
is really hard to record the Northern
Lights unless there's a moon out as well
but I used my cell phone to take some
pictures and those turned out really
well but I sat in bed and watched the
northern lights for like an hour before
I fell back asleep it was it was pretty
cool the Northern Lights kind of goes
through these Cycles and this year is
supposed to be a really good year to see
the Northern Lights I think I only saw
them three or four times last year but
so far this year this is my third time
seeing
them oh my pants have frost on them I'm
going to warm these
up this herbal tea comes in a jelly and
it's passion fruit puree it's got bits
of seeds and everything in it this
stuff's so
wonderful I made this mug from a cow
horn I also made this griddle quite a
few of my bush crafting tools I make
myself I did a video on how to make all
this stuff about a year ago I'll put a
link in the video description
below got some pork jow bacon left over
for my last trip going to let that cook
right
there
there we go a buttery hot tortilla
covered in cinnamon and
sugar if you like cinnamon toast you're
going to like
this buttery cinnamon and sugar
tortillas not bad
I think I need to get my pants on and
start cleaning
up this is a really nice shelter I I
enjoyed it but there was one thing about
the shelter I didn't get to show you if
you're ever camping on Sand or clean
gravel like this you can make a shelter
that is so warm you can sleep even in
the Deep winter without a sleeping bag
or tent let me show you what I mean
first thing you do is dig a shallow
trench you can lay down in then collect
tons of firewood doesn't need to be big
chunky stuff stuff like this is
perfect
got a nice bed of coals there now I'm
going to bury
it you want to make sure you use dry
sand or dry gravel if it's wet it'll
just turn it into a steam bath and put
the coals out you want to make really
sure you don't have any live coals that
aren't covered in gravel otherwise
you'll find out really quick when you
lay down if you do it at night it's a
lot easier to tell cuz they'll glow
orange in the dark got Steam from the
wet gravel coming on up oh that's
nice oh this is nice and toasty if
there's no snow on the ground and your
gravel's really dry you can do this in
about an hour if everything's covered in
snow it can take you 8 to 10 hours you
have to clear out all the snow melt all
the snow dry up all the water then you
can do this the key is the Santa gravel
has to be really dry if it's wet at all
it'll just put your coals right out if
you got a fire on one side and hot
gravel on your bottom it'll keep you
really warm in the past when I've done
this in the wintertime the gravel stayed
warm all night long but if you want you
can go ahead and build a nice long fire
next to you and if you wake up in the
night cold then you can just go and move
that fire over throw some gravel on it
and sleep over there and you can kind of
switch back and forth well this has been
a fun camping spot but I think it's time
to take it down and clean
up there we go looks
good well hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video if you want to see more
camping and Bush crafting videos check
out our playlist we have all of our
videos organized by playlist and don't
don't forget to click subscribe we'll
see you guys next video If you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning and hit that Bell
button so you'll get notifications
thanks for
watching